Speaker 1: So I want to speak a little bit about my
Speaker 1: understanding of the nature of the soul as
Speaker 1: it relates to the awakened, to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, and keep in mind that when we
Speaker 1: are speaking about such deep matters and
Speaker 1: the soul is a very deep matter we're
Speaker 1: entering into speculative inquiry.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to share with you my personal
Speaker 1: understanding, what I've come to but it's
Speaker 1: all a work in progress, remains a work in
Speaker 1: progress.
Speaker 1: I'm a work in progress, my ideas are a work
Speaker 1: in progress, but I think some of the
Speaker 1: distinctions I'm going to try and make some
Speaker 1: of you might find helpful.
Speaker 1: So, just to be clear, because I'm a teacher
Speaker 1: of enlightenment, everything that I speak
Speaker 1: about relates to the metaphysical context
Speaker 1: of the highest spiritual transformation,
Speaker 1: the most profound shift in consciousness
Speaker 1: that we know about, when it leads to
Speaker 1: unimaginable liberation and inner freedom
Speaker 1: and joy and happiness, contentment.
Speaker 1: So I'll speak.
Speaker 1: I want to describe a simple map, a way to
Speaker 1: understand this, a way to help you
Speaker 1: understand these distinctions in the
Speaker 1: context in which I'm speaking about it.
Speaker 1: So the soul, in the way we use the word,
Speaker 1: usually refers to one of the deepest parts
Speaker 1: of our humanity.
Speaker 1: One of the deepest parts of our humanity
Speaker 1: when we usually refer to our soul, or the
Speaker 1: soul, we're referring to a level of
Speaker 1: emotional and spiritual depth that is
Speaker 1: inherently meaningful.
Speaker 1: When people start speaking about the soul,
Speaker 1: we know that they're not speaking about
Speaker 1: superficial matters.
Speaker 1: They're speaking about matters that are
Speaker 1: deep and sincere and serious.
Speaker 1: So I want to talk about the nature of the
Speaker 1: soul in relationship to enlightenment.
Speaker 1: So we want to start with looking at the
Speaker 1: nature of the ego.
Speaker 1: The ego is the frontal cell.
Speaker 1: The ego plays a dominant role in the
Speaker 1: formation of the self-structure.
Speaker 1: It, the ego, is the organizing principle in
Speaker 1: the psyche.
Speaker 1: It creates coherence.
Speaker 1: So it's just to speak in very broad,
Speaker 1: general terms.
Speaker 1: If the ego is that structure in the psyche
Speaker 1: that creates coherence or a sense of
Speaker 1: wholeness, then we want that structure, the
Speaker 1: ego structure, to be in good shape.
Speaker 1: We want it to be healthy and vibrant and
Speaker 1: strong and coherent, because we all know
Speaker 1: that when the ego structure is not coherent
Speaker 1: or is incoherent, then usually the person
Speaker 1: is in trouble of some kind.
Speaker 1: So the ego is.
Speaker 1: The ego very much relates to the.
Speaker 1: In the way that I'm speaking about it now,
Speaker 1: very much relates to the structure of the
Speaker 1: personality and in the way I'm speaking
Speaker 1: about it now, we can interchangeably use
Speaker 1: the word ego to mean, in this context, the
Speaker 1: nature of Andrew's personality, the nature
Speaker 1: of Andrew's ego, for example, in the way
Speaker 1: I'm speaking about it now, I'm not speaking
Speaker 1: about the ego as a demon, because often in
Speaker 1: Enlightenment contexts, the ego is the
Speaker 1: demon that we need to transcend in order to
Speaker 1: be spiritually liberated, which is also
Speaker 1: true, but that's not the context in which
Speaker 1: I'm speaking about it for this talk.
Speaker 1: So, for this talk, we want to understand
Speaker 1: the ego.
Speaker 1: Structure is the is that structure that
Speaker 1: coheres to personality.
Speaker 1: It creates a healthy, integrated frontal
Speaker 1: self, what Ken Wilber would call the
Speaker 1: frontal self.
Speaker 1: And just to add to that, of course, the ego
Speaker 1: can have positive expressions and negative
Speaker 1: expressions.
Speaker 1: It can be a positive ego and a negative ego,
Speaker 1: a happy ego and a sad ego, a joyous ego and
Speaker 1: an angry ego, a liberated ego and a
Speaker 1: victimized ego.
Speaker 1: I'm sure you all know what I'm talking
Speaker 1: about from your own experience.
Speaker 1: You all know what I'm talking about from
Speaker 1: your own experience.
Speaker 1: But the ego, the ego is not the deepest
Speaker 1: part of the self, and so whenever we hear
Speaker 1: people refer to the soul, refer to my, I
Speaker 1: feel it in my soul.
Speaker 1: I could feel it in my soul, I could feel it
Speaker 1: in her soul.
Speaker 1: We were always pointing, when we speak that
Speaker 1: way, we were generally pointing to a deeper
Speaker 1: structure in the self, a deeper structure
Speaker 1: than the frontal self, a deeper structure
Speaker 1: than the personality, than the egoic
Speaker 1: personality, referring to a deeper
Speaker 1: dimension of the self that generally is
Speaker 1: considered to be more authentic and carry
Speaker 1: more truth, whatever that means.
Speaker 1: I'm just saying that usually, when we
Speaker 1: ourselves refer to our own souls or the
Speaker 1: soul of another, we're referring to deeper
Speaker 1: dimensions of the self than is the ego or
Speaker 1: the parental personality.
Speaker 1: He has a very deep soul, she is a deep soul,
Speaker 1: she's an old soul, for example.
Speaker 1: She is a deep soul, she's an old soul, for
Speaker 1: example.
Speaker 1: So I was talking about the nature of the
Speaker 1: ego, the soul and the true self.
Speaker 1: And the true self is from a spiritual
Speaker 1: perspective, from a metaphysical
Speaker 1: perspective, from the perspective of the
Speaker 1: perennial philosophy.
Speaker 1: The true self is the deepest dimension of
Speaker 1: the self, and the deepest dimension of
Speaker 1: reality itself relates to our personal
Speaker 1: history.
Speaker 1: The soul relates to, I believe, all the
Speaker 1: experience we've ever had as an evolving
Speaker 1: soul or, if one would believe it or think
Speaker 1: that way, over many lifetimes.
Speaker 1: And the self, the true self, exists from an
Speaker 1: inner realm of dimension of reality that is
Speaker 1: timeless and formless and beginning and
Speaker 1: endless and ultimately eternal.
Speaker 1: And remember, when I'm speaking about the
Speaker 1: ego and the soul and the true self, I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about myself, I'm speaking about
Speaker 1: yourself.
Speaker 1: So when we make these kinds of distinctions,
Speaker 1: we don't want to get too abstract about it,
Speaker 1: but we want to relate to, we want to try
Speaker 1: and locate the sense of being, the sense of
Speaker 1: being an ego or a unique personality,
Speaker 1: within ourself.
Speaker 1: As we're on an inquiry like this, we want
Speaker 1: to find our own ego and we want to find our
Speaker 1: own soul, which is a good thing to find.
Speaker 1: People that haven't found their own souls
Speaker 1: are generally not in great shape and, for
Speaker 1: the seekers after enlightenment, we want to
Speaker 1: find our true self.
Speaker 1: Our true self is the part of ourself,
Speaker 1: because it is one with eternity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where we find unconditional
Speaker 1: freedom, because it's a place where time
Speaker 1: does not exist.
Speaker 1: The true self is a source of spiritual
Speaker 1: freedom, yeah, inner freedom, spiritual
Speaker 1: liberation.
Speaker 1: So the ego is the source of the feelings of
Speaker 1: being a unique personal entity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where we experience pride, the
Speaker 1: experience of the process that most of us
Speaker 1: find ourselves in the midst of, of having a
Speaker 1: personal experience.
Speaker 1: It's when experience it happens in time,
Speaker 1: it's when experience feels very personal
Speaker 1: and unique to me.
Speaker 1: The ego is the source of this feeling of a
Speaker 1: personal process, of a personal event
Speaker 1: happening.
Speaker 1: That's the self-structure in which feels,
Speaker 1: in which the experience of embodied
Speaker 1: consciousness is experienced as being a
Speaker 1: personal event, something that's happening
Speaker 1: to a unique self of me.
Speaker 1: So I always like to say that the soul, what
Speaker 1: I'm calling the soul, is the deepest part
Speaker 1: of the self that's still personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul is the deepest part of the self
Speaker 1: that's still personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul comes from a much deeper source
Speaker 1: and I like to refer to the soul as the
Speaker 1: metaphysical organ.
Speaker 1: We could call it that, for lack of a better
Speaker 1: way of putting it.
Speaker 1: The soul is a metaphysical organ that
Speaker 1: carries with it.
Speaker 1: If you believe in the continuity of
Speaker 1: consciousness and I very much believe I
Speaker 1: can't prove it to you, but I very much
Speaker 1: believe in the continuity of consciousness
Speaker 1: I believe that the self, or that our soul,
Speaker 1: is on a journey of becoming in the context
Speaker 1: of evolution, just so, just with the rest
Speaker 1: of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: So the soul would be the receptacle which
Speaker 1: would contain all the memories of all the
Speaker 1: experiences you've ever had, going back to
Speaker 1: the very beginning of time and even the
Speaker 1: beginning of the universe.
Speaker 1: I believe that when I say it's something I
Speaker 1: believe, it's something that I'm.
Speaker 1: It's really a belief.
Speaker 1: I can't prove to you.
Speaker 1: But the soul is the metaphysical vessel
Speaker 1: that remains a constant and that is, I
Speaker 1: believe, in a process of growth and
Speaker 1: development through different incarnations
Speaker 1: and different processes of embodied
Speaker 1: consciousness over time.
Speaker 1: But the soul is a place where we experience
Speaker 1: our deepest emotions, our deepest feelings
Speaker 1: that still have a connection to our
Speaker 1: personal sense of self-identity.
Speaker 1: But these are deeper kinds of feelings.
Speaker 1: We could say in this context that the ego
Speaker 1: experiences all kinds of emotions and
Speaker 1: feelings, likes and dislikes.
Speaker 1: But the preferences and likes and dislikes
Speaker 1: of the ego in this context would be
Speaker 1: considered to be would be considered much
Speaker 1: more superficial in general than the
Speaker 1: feelings that we experience at the level of
Speaker 1: our souls.
Speaker 1: So for, for example, maybe we meet, as some
Speaker 1: people like to talk about, maybe we meet
Speaker 1: our soulmate.
Speaker 1: When I met her, I recognized
Speaker 1: instantaneously and miraculously that she
Speaker 1: was my soulmate and that we'd been waiting
Speaker 1: for each other for years.
Speaker 1: That kind of thing.
Speaker 1: It's when we experience deeper kinds of
Speaker 1: non-superficial, deeper kinds of feelings
Speaker 1: that relate to our experience of life.
Speaker 1: But these feelings are occurring in a much
Speaker 1: deeper strata dimension of experience.
Speaker 1: We feel deeper connections and deeper
Speaker 1: contexts.
Speaker 1: The dimension of experience we feel deeper
Speaker 1: connections and deeper contexts, maybe a
Speaker 1: deeper sense of meaning and also maybe a
Speaker 1: deeper sense of loss and grief,
Speaker 1: relationships and loss and grief.
Speaker 1: But the soul is the dimension of ourself
Speaker 1: where we experience our deepest feelings
Speaker 1: that are still related to ourselves
Speaker 1: personally but are much deeper than the
Speaker 1: realm of the kinds of emotions we
Speaker 1: experience at the level of the, of
Speaker 1: spiritual evolution is to train ourselves
Speaker 1: to cease to experience life from the
Speaker 1: vantage point that is so superficial to a
Speaker 1: vantage point perspective that's much
Speaker 1: deeper, much more authentic, much more
Speaker 1: meaningful and therefore has inherently
Speaker 1: greater value.
Speaker 1: One feels with people that are very
Speaker 1: superficial that they're just skirting
Speaker 1: along on the surface of life because
Speaker 1: they're not connected to any deeper parts
Speaker 1: of themselves or deeper parts of reality,
Speaker 1: and that can be tedious and unsatisfying
Speaker 1: for people with greater depth.
Speaker 1: But when you meet people who have greater
Speaker 1: depth, you feel that you're meeting them at
Speaker 1: the level of the soul and then there seems
Speaker 1: to be a sense of greater value in those
Speaker 1: kinds of connections and experiences.
Speaker 1: Value, purpose, meaning gravitas, sense of
Speaker 1: this means something of value.
Speaker 1: This is very important.
Speaker 1: This kind of feeling gives the experience
Speaker 1: of being alive value and meaning, which is
Speaker 1: so important in the human experience.
Speaker 1: Experience, value, now this, when we go
Speaker 1: deeper than that, the realm of the self,
Speaker 1: the true self that spiritual realizers
Speaker 1: refer to as the true self, that's the realm
Speaker 1: of eternity consciousness, of non-dual
Speaker 1: eternity consciousness.
Speaker 1: So the deepest dimension of the self, which
Speaker 1: is synonymous with the deepest dimension of
Speaker 1: reality itself, is a place where we
Speaker 1: experience the deepest quality and
Speaker 1: experience of I-ness, of selfness, of
Speaker 1: I-ness.
Speaker 1: But at that level of depth it's completely
Speaker 1: impersonal.
Speaker 1: There's no unique characteristics or
Speaker 1: features to the true self.
Speaker 1: The true self is often referred to as the
Speaker 1: ground of being.
Speaker 1: So it's an eternal ground that exists
Speaker 1: beyond time and beyond space and beyond
Speaker 1: form and beyond conception.
Speaker 1: But it's a place where you and I experience
Speaker 1: the fullest, deepest and most profound
Speaker 1: experience of conscious existence.
Speaker 1: But in that level we experience ourself as
Speaker 1: existing eternally, for eternity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where awareness is absolute
Speaker 1: and existence is, as I was saying, eternal,
Speaker 1: and it is absolutely and totally unrelated
Speaker 1: to any kind of relative experience that
Speaker 1: your soul or that your ego has in any other
Speaker 1: kind of context, or that your ego has in
Speaker 1: any other kind of context.
Speaker 1: So we have the ego, positive and negative.
Speaker 1: We have the soul, we have the true self Now,
Speaker 1: the soul, which is, as I was, as I've been
Speaker 1: saying, which is the deepest part of the
Speaker 1: yourself and myself that's still personal.
Speaker 1: It's where we experience our deepest, our
Speaker 1: deeper and more significant feelings and
Speaker 1: preferences and fears and yearnings and
Speaker 1: values.
Speaker 1: What we experience in our soul depends upon
Speaker 1: our level of consciousness development on
Speaker 1: one hand, and on the other hand, it depends
Speaker 1: on what we hold as being most dear or the
Speaker 1: greatest value to us hold as being most
Speaker 1: dear and one of the greatest value to us.
Speaker 1: So in integral philosophy, they had some
Speaker 1: basic, basic distinctions in terms of the
Speaker 1: evolutionary stages that the self goes
Speaker 1: through, and we'll just go through the most
Speaker 1: most basic ones for the sake of the talk
Speaker 1: I'm giving to you here.
Speaker 1: It's tonight where you are might be morning,
Speaker 1: but the lowest level is called egocentric
Speaker 1: and at the egocentric level is the
Speaker 1: consciousness of the small child, of the
Speaker 1: baby, who is completely identified with his
Speaker 1: or her biological impulses, his or her
Speaker 1: fears and desires.
Speaker 1: It's a state of uncontained, absolute
Speaker 1: narcissism and self-concern.
Speaker 1: It's a place we all start from and a place
Speaker 1: some of us, hopefully, will graduate from
Speaker 1: at some point in our evolutionary ascent,
Speaker 1: but some people never do so.
Speaker 1: Egocentric, the next stage of the
Speaker 1: self-development is called ethnocentric.
Speaker 1: And at the ethnocentric level we identify
Speaker 1: very much with our bloodline, with our
Speaker 1: family and our tribe.
Speaker 1: It's tribal consciousness.
Speaker 1: That's where our self sense is very
Speaker 1: intensely identified with our clan, with
Speaker 1: our tribe, with our family, that kind of
Speaker 1: blood belonging.
Speaker 1: And next level is world-centric, which is a
Speaker 1: very high level of consciousness
Speaker 1: development which is considered to be the
Speaker 1: leading edge in the world today, which is
Speaker 1: the identification, the universal nature of
Speaker 1: being a human being.
Speaker 1: I see myself first and foremost as a human
Speaker 1: being, as a member of the human family.
Speaker 1: So an individual at a world-centric,
Speaker 1: universal human level of development will
Speaker 1: see all human beings as his brothers and
Speaker 1: his sisters.
Speaker 1: And the highest level, the one level beyond
Speaker 1: that which is the goal that all spiritual
Speaker 1: seekers after enlightenment yearn for and
Speaker 1: work towards, is called cosmocentric.
Speaker 1: The cosmocentric level is when we identify
Speaker 1: with the evolutionary process itself as a
Speaker 1: source of our self-sense.
Speaker 1: I am the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe, bearing witness to
Speaker 1: itself and awakening to itself through the
Speaker 1: body-mind personality of Andrew or any one
Speaker 1: of you.
Speaker 1: So we have these basic, simple distinctions
Speaker 1: here.
Speaker 1: There are more distinctions, but I'm trying
Speaker 1: to keep it very simple for the point I want
Speaker 1: to make in this talk.
Speaker 1: So we have egocentric, ethnocentric
Speaker 1: identifying with the clan and the bloodline,
Speaker 1: world-centric, universal, human and
Speaker 1: cosmocentric identification with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary principle itself and
Speaker 1: evolutionary principle itself.
Speaker 1: Now, the fundamental point I want to make
Speaker 1: is that what I'm calling the soul here,
Speaker 1: what I'm keep on referring to as the soul,
Speaker 1: this very, this deepest part of the self
Speaker 1: that's still personal, where we have these
Speaker 1: very powerful and profound emotions that
Speaker 1: carry with them a great sense of importance
Speaker 1: and gravitas and significance.
Speaker 1: What, what you will feel in your soul as
Speaker 1: being that of the greatest importance,
Speaker 1: depends upon which state of consciousness
Speaker 1: you are resting in.
Speaker 1: So if you are, if you're at an ethnocentric
Speaker 1: stage of development where your primary
Speaker 1: identification is with your family or your
Speaker 1: tribe or your blood group, your clan, the
Speaker 1: deepest feelings that you will experience
Speaker 1: in your soul, your soul, felt emotions, the
Speaker 1: strongest emotions, positive and negative
Speaker 1: place where you experience the most
Speaker 1: gravitas emotionally, will stem from your
Speaker 1: will, stem from that level of development.
Speaker 1: So your strongest feelings and your soul
Speaker 1: will relate to your identification with
Speaker 1: being part of a particular tribe or a
Speaker 1: particular family and your strongest
Speaker 1: emotions are going to be very related to
Speaker 1: that stage of development.
Speaker 1: And we know, when people start to feel
Speaker 1: strong feelings in their soul, they're
Speaker 1: capable of great heroism in one hand and
Speaker 1: great evil on the other.
Speaker 1: Because when we feel strong emotions in our
Speaker 1: soul, because it's coming from our soul, we
Speaker 1: tend to never doubt the inherent value and
Speaker 1: what we imagine is an inherent truthfulness
Speaker 1: of what we're experiencing, because the
Speaker 1: feelings are so strong at that level, we
Speaker 1: feel these feelings so strongly at that
Speaker 1: level that we feel this is truth.
Speaker 1: That's why we that's why when we meet
Speaker 1: somebody that we consider to be our soul
Speaker 1: mate, it's so powerful.
Speaker 1: I have no doubt.
Speaker 1: I've been waiting for you for a hundred
Speaker 1: lifetimes.
Speaker 1: Maybe it's true, maybe it's not true, but
Speaker 1: because we feel it so intensely in our soul,
Speaker 1: we have no doubt that it's true.
Speaker 1: So egocentric, ethnocentric, so it's the
Speaker 1: same thing with world-centric, universal
Speaker 1: human values and feelings.
Speaker 1: A lot of people, for very noble reasons,
Speaker 1: feel at the level of their soul how
Speaker 1: important it is that there's human rights
Speaker 1: and fairness and justice in this world and
Speaker 1: the flourishing of liberal democracies and
Speaker 1: the freedom for women and oppressed peoples
Speaker 1: everywhere.
Speaker 1: It comes to the end of racism and sexism
Speaker 1: and patriarchy and so many things, because
Speaker 1: we recognize that all human beings are part
Speaker 1: of one species.
Speaker 1: We're all brothers and sisters and
Speaker 1: therefore we need to make this world a fair
Speaker 1: place.
Speaker 1: But some people feel that in their soul
Speaker 1: this is a soul-felt conviction.
Speaker 1: It's not something that is just believed
Speaker 1: and understood with the mind, it's a
Speaker 1: soul-felt conviction.
Speaker 1: And when you feel something like that so
Speaker 1: strongly in your soul, it's something you
Speaker 1: might be willing to die for and fight for.
Speaker 1: It's not a judgment.
Speaker 1: I'm just trying to make a point and then
Speaker 1: and then we go from world-centric to
Speaker 1: cosmocentric, centric to Cosmo centric.
Speaker 1: So when you which is a very rare level of
Speaker 1: attainment I am the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that created the universe, bearing with
Speaker 1: it's, bearing witness to itself through the
Speaker 1: body, mind, body, mind and personality of
Speaker 1: each and every one of us, that's when, when
Speaker 1: we relate to and identify with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary process from our souls, that's
Speaker 1: when it becomes a, there's a realness about
Speaker 1: that stage of development that becomes
Speaker 1: different because we feel it in our souls.
Speaker 1: So one of the points I wanted to make was
Speaker 1: that many of us relate to our experience,
Speaker 1: to our intellects.
Speaker 1: We're capable of so much understanding.
Speaker 1: We understand egocentrism and narcissism.
Speaker 1: We understand ethnocentric, tribal
Speaker 1: perspectives and feelings, at least to a
Speaker 1: point, we recognize feelings of
Speaker 1: universality, the universal nature of being
Speaker 1: human, which is a world-centric perspective,
Speaker 1: and world-centric feelings, and then
Speaker 1: there's cosmocentric.
Speaker 1: So what I'm saying is we can understand
Speaker 1: these distinctions with our intellects.
Speaker 1: We can appreciate them intellectually,
Speaker 1: metaphorically, at a level of abstraction.
Speaker 1: And then there's the level of actual
Speaker 1: feeling, of deep, soul-level feeling, and
Speaker 1: one of the points I wanted to make was that
Speaker 1: when we experience these distinctions at a
Speaker 1: soul level, we're not just understanding
Speaker 1: these distinctions at a level of mind and
Speaker 1: mental or intellectual abstraction, but
Speaker 1: we're understanding them with our gut, with
Speaker 1: our soul, the deepest nature of ourself.
Speaker 1: And because, basically, what I'm speaking
Speaker 1: about has to do with what is it that we
Speaker 1: care about the most?
Speaker 1: What is it that you care about the most?
Speaker 1: With?
Speaker 1: What is it that we care about the most.
Speaker 1: What is it that you care about the most?
Speaker 1: What is it that I care about the most?
Speaker 1: Because what we care about the most will be
Speaker 1: reflected in our soul level, in this
Speaker 1: experience we're having at the level of our
Speaker 1: souls.
Speaker 1: So what do you really care about the most?
Speaker 1: What you care about the most is what you
Speaker 1: feel in your soul, and a big part of the
Speaker 1: higher and more profound levels of
Speaker 1: spiritual transformation has to do with, I
Speaker 1: believe, the evolution of our capacity to
Speaker 1: care about higher matters at the level of
Speaker 1: our souls.
Speaker 1: So, to repeat, I believe that a very
Speaker 1: significant part of what higher spiritual
Speaker 1: development is about is learning how to
Speaker 1: care, learning what it means to deeply care,
Speaker 1: in this case about the evolution of
Speaker 1: consciousness, not from your mind, not
Speaker 1: appreciating that this would be a very good
Speaker 1: idea and makes reasonable sense, but that
Speaker 1: you begin to care because your soul has
Speaker 1: awakened to that level of consciousness, to
Speaker 1: its significance, and then you begin to
Speaker 1: care, beyond what your mind may think from
Speaker 1: time to time, about the evolution of
Speaker 1: consciousness for its own sake, because
Speaker 1: your soul has awakened to that level of
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: So the soul has to do with what you care
Speaker 1: about the most.
Speaker 1: Where are you rooted in your deepest
Speaker 1: preferences, preferences now, when we look
Speaker 1: at that question superficially, we find
Speaker 1: that for most people it's egoic,
Speaker 1: self-concern, survival at lower levels and
Speaker 1: beyond survival.
Speaker 1: It has to do with egocentric, unfortunately
Speaker 1: often materialistic survival, materialistic
Speaker 1: survival, materialistic self concern and
Speaker 1: narcissistic self concern.
Speaker 1: Not an awakened souls, feeling of
Speaker 1: overwhelming value about the nature and the
Speaker 1: nature and inherent meaning of
Speaker 1: self-existence, the significance of
Speaker 1: consciousness and the significance of the
Speaker 1: evolution of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: What are you living for?
Speaker 1: Because we can't really live for spirit and
Speaker 1: for these higher spiritual values unless we
Speaker 1: have awakened, at the level of the soul,
Speaker 1: these higher principles.
Speaker 1: So the question I'm asking is where is any
Speaker 1: one of us at the level of our soul?
Speaker 1: So often we find that for many people our
Speaker 1: soul is very much related to materialistic
Speaker 1: concerns and narcissistic concerns,
Speaker 1: heaven-centric concerns.
Speaker 1: But when your soul is related to these
Speaker 1: deeper dimensions of the self and deeper
Speaker 1: dimensions of reality, this is when
Speaker 1: spiritual evolution begins to happen for
Speaker 1: real.
Speaker 1: It's when you become a truly transformed,
Speaker 1: sentient being.
Speaker 1: That's when the soul begins to get, when
Speaker 1: the soul literally begins to identify
Speaker 1: itself with unqualified spirit and
Speaker 1: something really changes in each and every
Speaker 1: one of us at the deepest level.
Speaker 1: It's when your soul gets so drenched in the
Speaker 1: consciousness of eternity, for example,
Speaker 1: that it's something you can't forget, you
Speaker 1: can't turn away from.
Speaker 1: You've been so deeply touched that your
Speaker 1: soul is now awakened to eternity and it's
Speaker 1: something that your soul knows about.
Speaker 1: Now, your soul knows about eternity.
Speaker 1: It's not that your ego had a great
Speaker 1: experience that it remembers, but it's
Speaker 1: something about eternity.
Speaker 1: It's not that your ego had a great
Speaker 1: experience that it remembers, but it's
Speaker 1: something that you know, it's something
Speaker 1: that your soul knows and your soul, the
Speaker 1: soul, never forgets.
Speaker 1: The soul is the most important part of each
Speaker 1: and every one of us.
Speaker 1: The soul is the source of our integrity, or
Speaker 1: lack of integrity.
Speaker 1: The soul is where we find our capacity for
Speaker 1: wholeness and integration.
Speaker 1: Deep kindness, unselfish deep kindness,
Speaker 1: love, loyalty, care, selflessness or not.
Speaker 1: I believe it's the soul, it's that
Speaker 1: dimension of ourselves where we have that
Speaker 1: rude awakening.
Speaker 1: Rude awakening is when you get a glimpse of
Speaker 1: the totality of reality, whatever way it
Speaker 1: happens, and you glimpse, for maybe an
Speaker 1: instant, where you're really at in
Speaker 1: relationship to the experience of being
Speaker 1: human.
Speaker 1: For a moment, you glimpse your true motives
Speaker 1: and it may be a rude awakening.
Speaker 1: You might find out that you're not as true,
Speaker 1: authentic and pure well-meaning, as you may
Speaker 1: imagine yourself to be, or you may find
Speaker 1: that you are, that the place you find it,
Speaker 1: the place within yourself that you find out
Speaker 1: the answers to these kinds of questions is
Speaker 1: in your soul.
Speaker 1: So, for example, when you can hear some
Speaker 1: people speak about their spiritual
Speaker 1: experiences, some people will speak, maybe
Speaker 1: in a very articulate and intellectually
Speaker 1: coherent way, about higher states and
Speaker 1: higher state experiences that they may have
Speaker 1: had.
Speaker 1: But have they been touched at the level of
Speaker 1: the soul by those experiences or has it
Speaker 1: really been an interesting process that
Speaker 1: they went through that still leaves them
Speaker 1: fundamentally unchanged?
Speaker 1: When we're touched at the level of our soul,
Speaker 1: it's impossible for us to remain unchanged.
Speaker 1: And the longer that I live and the longer
Speaker 1: that I teach and the more experience I have,
Speaker 1: I think that the development of the soul,
Speaker 1: the conscious development of the soul, the
Speaker 1: conscious cultivation of the soul, might be
Speaker 1: the most important part of spiritual
Speaker 1: practice and being involved in the
Speaker 1: spiritual process.
Speaker 1: Because, as to repeat what I said a few
Speaker 1: minutes ago, because the soul is the place
Speaker 1: where we find our capacity, or lack of
Speaker 1: capacity, for authenticity, deep
Speaker 1: trustworthiness, gravitas and
Speaker 1: single-pointedness in relationship to
Speaker 1: consciousness development and soul
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: Now, in Western postmodern culture, the
Speaker 1: soul is not something we speak about that
Speaker 1: often, and often when I hear people speak
Speaker 1: about the soul in spiritual contexts,
Speaker 1: generally to make a gross generalization it
Speaker 1: often seems to have more to do with the
Speaker 1: ego's deeper feelings than anything else.
Speaker 1: The soul is that part of ourself in which
Speaker 1: we glimpse what a deadly serious matter the
Speaker 1: gift of life is, the gift of conscious life,
Speaker 1: the gift of life that is consciously
Speaker 1: experienced in the context of
Speaker 1: self-reflective awareness.
Speaker 1: The soul is the place where we realize this
Speaker 1: is not a game.
Speaker 1: We're not going to get any second chances
Speaker 1: necessarily, that everything counts.
Speaker 1: The karma is real, there's no way out,
Speaker 1: there's no escape.
Speaker 1: There's no way out, there's no escape.
Speaker 1: And it's where we awaken to this shocking
Speaker 1: recognition that this is it, when, always,
Speaker 1: now, in the present moment, that this is
Speaker 1: really it, that this really counts, that
Speaker 1: all the important choices we make really
Speaker 1: count, and there's no extricating ourselves
Speaker 1: from a karmic momentum.
Speaker 1: We're all part and parcel of a very complex
Speaker 1: process of karmic momentum.
Speaker 1: We can't disentangle ourselves from it, but
Speaker 1: we can, through spiritual practice,
Speaker 1: cultivate the capacity to consciously add
Speaker 1: that which is most positive to the
Speaker 1: complexity of the karmic process that we
Speaker 1: are entangled in, we can, through our own
Speaker 1: focused intention, bring some genuine
Speaker 1: positivity to the process.
Speaker 1: That's real, that will affect the process
Speaker 1: as a whole in its own way, because a lot of
Speaker 1: us like to think of ourselves as somehow
Speaker 1: not responsible and somehow that we're
Speaker 1: standing outside this vast cosmic process
Speaker 1: watching as kind of observers, observers
Speaker 1: and victims, not co-creators.
Speaker 1: But when we wake up, in the way that I've
Speaker 1: been describing, we realize we're always
Speaker 1: co-creators, whether we're conscious of it
Speaker 1: or not.
Speaker 1: We're always co-creators, whether we're
Speaker 1: conscious of it or not.
Speaker 1: We're always called creators, whether we're
Speaker 1: And when you really begin to wake up, you
Speaker 1: realize, number one, that that's true,
Speaker 1: there's no time off or days off, the time
Speaker 1: out and everything counts, and that the
Speaker 1: state of consciousness, in the state of
Speaker 1: development of our souls, is all important,
Speaker 1: because that will indicate the ways in
Speaker 1: which we're going to be able to contribute
Speaker 1: positively or not to this cosmic unfolding
Speaker 1: that we're part and parcel of always.
Speaker 1: So in this context, we can think about the
Speaker 1: processes in terms of spiritual practice
Speaker 1: and purification, the cultivation of
Speaker 1: purification and integration of higher
Speaker 1: wholeness and of a higher motivation,
Speaker 1: ultimately, not for our own sake, not for
Speaker 1: our own liberation, not for our own soul
Speaker 1: salvation, but so that we'll be able to
Speaker 1: contribute that which is unimaginably
Speaker 1: wholesome and purely positive to this
Speaker 1: unconscious hurricane that is the
Speaker 1: complexity of this cosmic process that
Speaker 1: we're in the midst of.
Speaker 1: There's so much positivity that we can
Speaker 1: bring to this If we're willing to make the
Speaker 1: effort to do so and to sacrifice ourselves,
Speaker 1: to sacrifice our egos, because the ego
Speaker 1: always has another agenda.
Speaker 1: I want to do this and I want to do that
Speaker 1: because it's all for me.
Speaker 1: I want to do this and I want to do that.
Speaker 1: The ego has an ego almost always has
Speaker 1: another agenda in mind, and when we begin
Speaker 1: to see ourselves, and when we can see
Speaker 1: ourselves and locate ourselves in the midst
Speaker 1: of this chaos and confusion, we begin to
Speaker 1: recognize how important our contribution,
Speaker 1: how as much positivity as possible is, not
Speaker 1: as a secondary contribution but as a
Speaker 1: fundamental contribution, as our essential
Speaker 1: gift to the universe, if we have enough
Speaker 1: courage to do it.
Speaker 1: So is your soul fundamentally identified
Speaker 1: with your ego and its fears and desires and
Speaker 1: grievances and frustrations and unresolved
Speaker 1: trauma?
Speaker 1: Is that what your soul is identified with?
Speaker 1: Is your soul identified with your bloodline,
Speaker 1: your biological identity and a profound
Speaker 1: sense of self-importance in the positive
Speaker 1: sense that that brings with it.
Speaker 1: Just think for a minute where is your soul
Speaker 1: identified?
Speaker 1: Identified?
Speaker 1: If you're interested in enlightenment in a
Speaker 1: serious way, then that would mean that your
Speaker 1: soul is identified with eternity, and which
Speaker 1: is birthless and deathless, timeless and
Speaker 1: formless and beginningless and endless.
Speaker 1: Or is your soul identified with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse God forces, the force
Speaker 1: of creativity as the universe in the
Speaker 1: universe and in this process?
Speaker 1: It's very important and very helpful to
Speaker 1: learn how to do to the practice of
Speaker 1: contemplative inquiry, contemplative
Speaker 1: self-scrutiny.
Speaker 1: Contemplative inquiry For you and I do this
Speaker 1: myself as often as possible, like every day
Speaker 1: is to learn how to practice to discriminate
Speaker 1: between the concerns of your ego and the
Speaker 1: concerns of your soul, because the ego can
Speaker 1: have very strong feelings, very strong
Speaker 1: likes and dislikes and all kinds of
Speaker 1: preferences, and they can be very
Speaker 1: distracting, we all know.
Speaker 1: But your soul feels things even more deeply
Speaker 1: than your ego does, as powerful as your
Speaker 1: egoic feelings can be.
Speaker 1: And are you aware, as you're going through
Speaker 1: the ups and downs, of how the ego might
Speaker 1: feel and how the soul might feel?
Speaker 1: Are you aware of the difference between the
Speaker 1: two?
Speaker 1: Because the soul is always very concerned
Speaker 1: with what you know and what feels most
Speaker 1: important.
Speaker 1: It's very important to understand that what
Speaker 1: I'm calling the true self, the grounded
Speaker 1: being, doesn't have preferences.
Speaker 1: It's free from all events or anything and
Speaker 1: everything that ever happens.
Speaker 1: The true self is free from and not
Speaker 1: identified with any of it.
Speaker 1: That's why it's the awakened soul that has
Speaker 1: to be our guide, because the true self is
Speaker 1: pure, unqualified, absolute is-ness.
Speaker 1: It doesn't make preferences, it doesn't
Speaker 1: make choices because it's always already
Speaker 1: free.
Speaker 1: So a big part of spiritual practice is
Speaker 1: learning how to distinguish between the
Speaker 1: soul's feelings and preferences and the
Speaker 1: ego's feelings and preferences.
Speaker 1: People who are living life from their soul
Speaker 1: are much deeper people, much deeper beings
Speaker 1: they are.
Speaker 1: They have more weight as sentient beings
Speaker 1: because they, because they're much more
Speaker 1: connected to depth and value and meaning
Speaker 1: and purpose and the significance of history
Speaker 1: and karma and direction.
Speaker 1: So we don't want to swim around on the
Speaker 1: surface of life, lost in the egos, fears
Speaker 1: and desires, likes and dislikes, as so many
Speaker 1: people do these days, lost, so deeply lost,
Speaker 1: and not even knowing that they're lost.
Speaker 1: Is it worse to be lost or is it worse to be
Speaker 1: lost and not know?
Speaker 1: And I think it's worse to be lost and not
Speaker 1: know?
Speaker 1: If you're lost and you know you're lost.
Speaker 1: You're not completely lost, but if you're
Speaker 1: lost and you don't know you're lost, then
Speaker 1: you're really lost.
Speaker 1: And if you think you're lost and it scares
Speaker 1: you, that's good.
Speaker 1: Sometimes it's good to be scared of being
Speaker 1: lost because it'll help you to care about
Speaker 1: deeper matters.
Speaker 1: So, as you meditate, as you practice in
Speaker 1: self-inquiry, as you practice contemplation,
Speaker 1: as you screw in your own internal thoughts
Speaker 1: and feelings, highs and lows, ups and downs,
Speaker 1: try to find out where you're at in
Speaker 1: relationship to your soul.
Speaker 1: What is your soul that you care about?
Speaker 1: What is your soul focused on?
Speaker 1: Where are you at in relationship to your
Speaker 1: soul?
Speaker 1: Because it's my belief I can't prove this,
Speaker 1: but it's my belief that the soul, as I said,
Speaker 1: is the metaphysical organ in which there's
Speaker 1: continuity from life to life.
Speaker 1: I always ask people is there continuity in
Speaker 1: the material process of the evolving cosmos?
Speaker 1: Is there continuity in the evolution of the
Speaker 1: energy and matter that make up the evolving
Speaker 1: universe?
Speaker 1: Is there continuity from the Big Bang until
Speaker 1: now?
Speaker 1: Is there continuity in the past 14 billion
Speaker 1: years of evolutionary becoming at the level
Speaker 1: of matter and energy?
Speaker 1: And then we'll say, yes, there's continuity.
Speaker 1: So if there's continuity at the level of
Speaker 1: energy and matter for the last 14 billion
Speaker 1: years at the level of matter and energy,
Speaker 1: which is considered to be the outside of
Speaker 1: the universe.
Speaker 1: Why would there not also be continuity on
Speaker 1: the inside, at the level of interiority?
Speaker 1: Because, as integral philosophies made us
Speaker 1: aware, the universe has an inside and an
Speaker 1: outside.
Speaker 1: Matter and energy of the exterior
Speaker 1: subjectivity, interiority are the inside.
Speaker 1: So if the exterior of the universe has
Speaker 1: continuity, it makes sense that the
Speaker 1: interior of the universe, which is
Speaker 1: interiority itself, is part of that
Speaker 1: continuity, that there is continuity in the
Speaker 1: interior of the evolving universe, in the
Speaker 1: inside of the evolving universe.
Speaker 1: What I've been referring to as the soul, I
Speaker 1: believe, is part and parcel of the
Speaker 1: continuity of that interiority.
Speaker 1: So what I'm calling the soul has been
Speaker 1: present in some partial form from the very
Speaker 1: beginning, or, if not from the very
Speaker 1: beginning, it's been part of this.
Speaker 1: That relates to the biggest vision of
Speaker 1: becoming your biggest and my biggest
Speaker 1: glimpse or vision or insight into the
Speaker 1: nature of being part of a cosmic process.
Speaker 1: It's been a process for a very long time.
Speaker 1: That's beginning to awaken to itself
Speaker 1: through you, through me, but it's glimpsing
Speaker 1: the significance of being part of this for
Speaker 1: so long, of being inherently meshed in this
Speaker 1: process for so long.
Speaker 1: And when you awaken to that and you
Speaker 1: recognize it, it's awe-inspiring and
Speaker 1: overwhelming Because it means we've all
Speaker 1: been here for a very long time.
Speaker 1: We just haven't known it.
Speaker 1: So as we wake up to how long we've been
Speaker 1: here, then the self tries to, then the self
Speaker 1: tries to grapple with how can I possibly
Speaker 1: take responsibility for all of this?
Speaker 1: Who am I if I've been around for all this
Speaker 1: time?
Speaker 1: Little old me.
Speaker 1: It's enormous, very challenging, daunting,
Speaker 1: very challenging, daunting.
Speaker 1: So how conscious are we to how big all this
Speaker 1: is and how profound it all really is?
Speaker 1: It all really is.
Speaker 1: The more we can face and come to terms with
Speaker 1: the enormity of this process that we are
Speaker 1: inherently a part and parcel of, the more
Speaker 1: profound will be the life that we live and
Speaker 1: our reasons for living it.
Speaker 1: Thank you, so your, your soul, or the soul,
Speaker 1: can see beyond the limitations of just this
Speaker 1: small life you're living, right.
Speaker 1: I'm not saying your life is small, but the
Speaker 1: limited nature of how we think about what
Speaker 1: it means to be alive.
Speaker 1: So the reason why it's so important to
Speaker 1: meditate every day is so that we will have
Speaker 1: these glimpses, which are often hard.
Speaker 1: When we get these glimpses, way beyond the
Speaker 1: narrow confines of our ego and its narrow
Speaker 1: relationship to personal history, when we
Speaker 1: get these glimpses, relationship to
Speaker 1: personal history, when we get these
Speaker 1: glimpses, it widens our perspective so much
Speaker 1: and awakens us to the shocking reality of a
Speaker 1: part of this and conceivably vast process
Speaker 1: that desperately needs us to be conscious
Speaker 1: of it.
Speaker 1: Sometimes, when I think in a in a mythic
Speaker 1: context, in a mythic, anthropocentric way,
Speaker 1: about the nature of the absolute principle
Speaker 1: or the God principle, just for fun,
Speaker 1: sometimes I choose to think about the
Speaker 1: nature of the absolute principle or the God
Speaker 1: principle just for fun.
Speaker 1: Sometimes I choose to think about the
Speaker 1: nature of the God principle as an
Speaker 1: anthropomorphic form, just as a
Speaker 1: metaphysical exercise.
Speaker 1: So in that context, sometimes I imagine how,
Speaker 1: if I was her, I'm being politically correct.
Speaker 1: Sometimes I imagine, if I was her, how
Speaker 1: desperate I would be for my children to
Speaker 1: wake up and to see me, because I knew, as
Speaker 1: long as they could see me, there would be
Speaker 1: hope for the future.
Speaker 1: But as long as they could see me there
Speaker 1: would be hope for the future.
Speaker 1: But as long as they couldn't really see me
Speaker 1: clearly and feel me and know who I was,
Speaker 1: they would remain lost in delusion.
Speaker 1: So that's an anthropocentric contemplation.
Speaker 1: But we don't have to think about it that
Speaker 1: way.
Speaker 1: We can say the reality of consciousness is
Speaker 1: desperate for its own self-recognition.
Speaker 1: The same thing, very good.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to stop myself now.
Speaker 1: But it's some kind of rambling.
Speaker 1: Very good, so I'm going to stop myself now
Speaker 1: because I'm kind of rambling.
Speaker 1: So I made the fundamental point I was
Speaker 1: trying to make, and the fundamental point
Speaker 1: was that your soul, or what we're calling
Speaker 1: the soul, your soul, my soul, the soul, its
Speaker 1: capacity for it, identifies with where
Speaker 1: you're at in terms of the stage of
Speaker 1: development you're at, from egocentric,
Speaker 1: ethnocentric, to world-centric, to
Speaker 1: cosmos-centric.
Speaker 1: So what your soul will be capable of in
Speaker 1: terms of identifying with what's most
Speaker 1: important will depend upon which stage of
Speaker 1: development you're at as an evolving
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: And remember that the soul is the deepest
Speaker 1: part of the self.
Speaker 1: It's still personal.
Speaker 1: The ego is purely personal.
Speaker 1: The frontal self or ego is purely personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul is a much deeper part of who
Speaker 1: you are and who I am, but it's still
Speaker 1: personal because it's still about that
Speaker 1: which experiences birth and death.
Speaker 1: It's going through, because it's still
Speaker 1: about that which experiences birth and
Speaker 1: death.
Speaker 1: It's going through a process of change.
Speaker 1: The true self, your true self and my true
Speaker 1: self, is the deepest dimension of who you
Speaker 1: are, the deepest dimension of your reality
Speaker 1: self, and it's never born and never dies,
Speaker 1: and it's therefore eternal and therefore
Speaker 1: has no preferences.
Speaker 1: So the true self doesn't care, your true
Speaker 1: self doesn't care.
Speaker 1: That's why it's free.
Speaker 1: That's why we could say that it might be
Speaker 1: more important to have an awakened soul
Speaker 1: than awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacities for care.
Speaker 1: I think awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacities for care is more important than
Speaker 1: the experience of inner freedom.
Speaker 1: Care and awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacity for care can be an enormous burden,
Speaker 1: because if you care, if you really care, if
Speaker 1: you allow yourself to care that much and to
Speaker 1: experience that much care, it means you're
Speaker 1: going to have to do something about it,
Speaker 1: whereas if you are merely free, you don't
Speaker 1: have to care.
Speaker 1: So sometimes, paradoxically, the pursuit of
Speaker 1: freedom for its own sake can be, can
Speaker 1: inhibit certain kinds of spiritual
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: Believe it or not, very good.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to stop talking now and then,
Speaker 1: in a couple of minutes, I can try and
Speaker 1: answer some questions, if you'd like.
Speaker 1: Let's hope we all will aspire to become
Speaker 1: soulful people, soul full people, soul full
Speaker 1: of soul, bursting with soul.
Speaker 3: Soul is care and care is soul.
Speaker 3: Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Speaker 3: So does anybody have any questions?
Speaker 3: Yeah, there are a few here, and please
Speaker 3: write your questions in the chat box at the
Speaker 3: bottom of the Zoom window.
Speaker 3: So Edwin is asking.
Speaker 1: Let me just find him Does
Speaker 1: self-transcendence lead to soul or to the
Speaker 1: true self?
Speaker 1: It usually leads to the true self.
Speaker 1: I mean, I guess it all depends upon who
Speaker 1: you're speaking to and how they define
Speaker 1: these terms, because not everybody uses
Speaker 1: these terms in the same way to mean the
Speaker 1: same thing.
Speaker 1: But generally speaking, my understanding of
Speaker 1: self-transcendence is the transcending the
Speaker 1: egoic consciousness to the, to the
Speaker 1: awareness of the ground of being, to
Speaker 1: eternity.
Speaker 1: Consciousness, that's, from being trapped
Speaker 1: in the ego's world of rampant fear and
Speaker 1: desire to awakening to eternity beyond any
Speaker 1: sense of being a unique individual.
Speaker 1: That's what's so liberating about
Speaker 1: transcendence is when we experience the
Speaker 1: true self on the ground of being, by the
Speaker 1: context of eternity.
Speaker 4: But doesn't one transcend?
Speaker 4: I mean, how does one move from ego to soul
Speaker 4: consciousness?
Speaker 4: There's not a transcendence, or how would
Speaker 4: you describe that shift?
Speaker 1: You don't have your screen on Edwin.
Speaker 1: Oh, I'll put your screen on Edwin.
Speaker 4: Oh, can I put your screen on please?
Speaker 4: Sorry, I do.
Speaker 4: Sorry it was off.
Speaker 1: That's okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, I think that the soul is
Speaker 1: something that we have to work for and
Speaker 1: something that either we will either we
Speaker 1: will realize it on our own accord, or
Speaker 1: someone is going to have to point it out to
Speaker 1: us, because some people are focused mainly
Speaker 1: on the experience of transcendence and
Speaker 1: inner freedom and are not very concerned
Speaker 1: about the cultivation of their souls yeah,
Speaker 1: I no, I really appreciate your, your talk
Speaker 1: about soul today, because I think I, you
Speaker 1: know, I use the term true self.
Speaker 4: Richard roar uses true self a lot and so I,
Speaker 4: I just uh was using true self as uh
Speaker 4: transcending ego to you know, know your
Speaker 4: true self, which you really I think it's
Speaker 4: really ego, soul that you're talking about.
Speaker 4: So thank you for that distinction.
Speaker 4: That's very helpful.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm making.
Speaker 1: I'm making a clear distinction in this.
Speaker 1: This is my mid evening from here, so I'm
Speaker 1: making a distinction between true self and
Speaker 1: soul.
Speaker 1: But there are some people who,
Speaker 1: understandably, could understand the true
Speaker 1: self and soul are not separate.
Speaker 1: But in my experience, in the way that I
Speaker 1: think about it, the soul is the
Speaker 1: metaphysical organ that transmigrates.
Speaker 1: It's my understanding and that it's a part
Speaker 1: of us that's been involved in this process
Speaker 1: as an evolving entity for a very long time
Speaker 1: and it's a deepest part of the self.
Speaker 1: It's still personal.
Speaker 4: You need to identify it with care, which
Speaker 4: then leads to action, whereas the danger of
Speaker 4: just like transcending to his suit to self
Speaker 4: could be this kind of being just a hermit
Speaker 4: and without a care for the world, and kind
Speaker 4: of thing yeah, the great trunk for you to
Speaker 4: define the ccl.
Speaker 1: Ccl means couldn't care less.
Speaker 1: Ccl means couldn't care less, because the
Speaker 1: point is when, when we awaken to the free,
Speaker 1: the freedom of the true self, we, you enter
Speaker 1: into a state of consciousness that's
Speaker 1: timeless and formless and beginningless and
Speaker 1: endless and eternal and birthless and
Speaker 1: deathless and absolutely free from karma.
Speaker 1: And in that state, in the, in the
Speaker 1: intoxicating ecstasy of that state, which
Speaker 1: is utterly and completely delightful,
Speaker 1: there's nothing wrong, yeah, and there are
Speaker 1: no problems to solve or overcome, because
Speaker 1: you are immersed in the conscious awareness
Speaker 1: of absolute, unqualifiable, radical Is-ness
Speaker 1: in all directions simultaneously.
Speaker 1: You're so absorbed in pure Is-ness that
Speaker 1: there is simply nothing to be done, because
Speaker 1: everything always is.
Speaker 1: And in that isness, is total, unconditional
Speaker 1: liberation.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 1: So you can see, edwin, that depending upon
Speaker 1: how we look at all this, depending on how
Speaker 1: we look about it, depending upon how we,
Speaker 1: what our values are, enlightenment could be
Speaker 1: seen as potentially, if it happens to the
Speaker 1: wrong person at the wrong time in their
Speaker 1: evolutionary trajectory of becoming, could
Speaker 1: be dangerous and have even a negative
Speaker 1: effect.
Speaker 1: And how much do?
Speaker 1: How much is any one of us capable of caring?
Speaker 1: How much do we want to care?
Speaker 1: How much do we want to be bothered with the
Speaker 1: burden of caring?
Speaker 1: Because caring takes heart and sometimes
Speaker 1: it's painful.
Speaker 1: So if I don't care and I'm free, I'm a
Speaker 1: little bit better off, I guess, because I
Speaker 1: don't have to struggle with the burden of
Speaker 1: care.
Speaker 4: You know.
Speaker 4: To be honest, I think you know I try to get
Speaker 4: other people to care.
Speaker 4: Is that caring?
Speaker 4: Am I caring enough?
Speaker 4: I mean yeah.
Speaker 1: How much is enough?
Speaker 1: Yeah, how much is enough?
Speaker 1: Yeah, because from my understanding of the
Speaker 1: awakening perspective, it's only enough
Speaker 1: when all the suffering, obsession, beings
Speaker 1: in the entire universe come to an end.
Speaker 1: Only then is it enough.
Speaker 1: And so what the small self can't handle is
Speaker 1: the overwhelming nature of reality.
Speaker 1: When we really let ourselves see and feel
Speaker 1: and understand this process, that works to
Speaker 1: do what Bob Kahn and Paras love.
Speaker 1: It breaks the set boundaries that the small
Speaker 1: self creates to live within and it's
Speaker 1: overwhelming in every possible direction.
Speaker 1: It makes the ego very uncomfortable and the
Speaker 1: ego wants to be comfortable, it doesn't
Speaker 1: want to be overwhelmed.
Speaker 1: Very good, thank you, edwin.
Speaker 3: Thank you the next question is from simone
Speaker 3: uh, the friend of pulse andrew, if you look
Speaker 3: for her.
Speaker 3: How do we begin to discriminate the
Speaker 3: difference between the soul and the
Speaker 3: positive ego?
Speaker 1: Can you ask the question again?
Speaker 1: I'm sorry.
Speaker 3: Yes, how do we begin to discriminate the
Speaker 3: difference between the soul and the
Speaker 3: positive ego?
Speaker 1: Well, that's a very good question.
Speaker 1: It's very astute.
Speaker 1: The thing is, the positive ego feels good
Speaker 1: about itself.
Speaker 1: So that's when I'm having a good day.
Speaker 1: So on a good, on a good, you know, because
Speaker 1: because somehow we can feel, we can feel
Speaker 1: crappy and lousy about ourselves, we can
Speaker 1: feel, you know, self-loathing and unworthy
Speaker 1: and self-hatred, as a lot of people do.
Speaker 1: Or we can have a good day, we could feel
Speaker 1: very positive, maybe did some good things,
Speaker 1: maybe we were creatively very productive
Speaker 1: and done some great things and we could
Speaker 1: feel good about ourselves.
Speaker 1: So the positive ego feels good about itself.
Speaker 1: But the soul, soul cares about more than
Speaker 1: just itself.
Speaker 1: The soul cares about karma, cares about
Speaker 1: reality as a whole and our relationship to
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: The positive ego and we all want to have a
Speaker 1: positive ego.
Speaker 1: I'm all for positive ego.
Speaker 1: Negative ego is what creates the problem.
Speaker 1: So positive ego is important, but the ego
Speaker 1: is still all about me, whereas with the
Speaker 1: soul you're always going to be aware of
Speaker 1: your relationship to life, with a capital L
Speaker 1: and karma with a capital K, and meaning and
Speaker 1: purpose with a capital M and P.
Speaker 1: So in the soul you're always going to see
Speaker 1: yourself and your relationship to life in
Speaker 1: these bigger and bigger contexts and you're
Speaker 1: going to feel good about it or bad about it,
Speaker 1: or you're going to feel moved to want to
Speaker 1: respond because you're seeing your own
Speaker 1: relationship, your place in reality, your
Speaker 1: relationship to reality, in a much bigger
Speaker 1: way.
Speaker 1: Positive ego doesn't necessarily do that,
Speaker 1: it's context.
Speaker 1: So we feel the larger context very deeply
Speaker 1: and it moves us, it touches us.
Speaker 1: Does that help?
Speaker 3: yes, I guess in a sense what I understand
Speaker 3: is that the positive ego in a way gives you
Speaker 3: feedback, but it doesn't help you zoom out
Speaker 3: or inspire you in a way.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly.
Speaker 1: I'm just saying that the positive ego cares
Speaker 1: about itself.
Speaker 1: I'm a good person, I'm a capable person.
Speaker 1: I'm a capable person, I'm a smart person,
Speaker 1: I'm a kind person, I'm a generous person.
Speaker 1: It's all about me.
Speaker 1: And if all those things are true about me,
Speaker 1: that's good.
Speaker 1: It's all good.
Speaker 1: It's all good news.
Speaker 1: The positive ego is how I feel about myself.
Speaker 1: The positive ego is how I feel about myself,
Speaker 1: whereas with the soul, the soul is suddenly,
Speaker 1: you see your own unique self in
Speaker 1: relationship to the reality of karma and we
Speaker 1: could say big history, and you start
Speaker 1: feeling this overwhelming context in which
Speaker 1: you actually exist and then you start to
Speaker 1: see that the ego story is so small and when
Speaker 1: you awaken to the soul, you realize that
Speaker 1: the story that you have been immersed in
Speaker 1: for God knows how long is profound and
Speaker 1: intense and overwhelmingly demanding.
Speaker 1: When we begin to feel it at the level of
Speaker 1: the soul, it's kind of all emotionally can
Speaker 1: be overwhelming in good ways and bad ways.
Speaker 1: But it's seeing much more of the truth with
Speaker 1: a capital T Because, for example, you know,
Speaker 1: when we have spiritual insights, a lot of
Speaker 1: people think about it in a crude way that
Speaker 1: everybody wants to be good with God.
Speaker 1: And when we start seeing the reality from
Speaker 1: the vantage point of our own in soul, we
Speaker 1: start seeing how we could have a much more,
Speaker 1: have a much deeper relationship to life.
Speaker 1: That expressed deep integrity.
Speaker 1: And I think integrity, from my perspective,
Speaker 1: is expressing how much we actually care
Speaker 1: about more than ourselves and actually
Speaker 1: express it in the way we live our lives
Speaker 1: thank you sure the next question is from
Speaker 1: carrie.
Speaker 3: She's asking does the karmic field reside
Speaker 3: in the memory rather than in the soul?
Speaker 1: well, I mean, I don't really know the
Speaker 1: answer to the question, but I would say
Speaker 1: that the the memory we're speaking,
Speaker 1: personal memory, resides in the ego and the
Speaker 1: deeper memory resides in the soul.
Speaker 5: So how does one go about loosening the
Speaker 5: connection to your imprints?
Speaker 5: To the what Carrie Sorry to the what Carrie,
Speaker 5: sorry, the imprints of all the causes and
Speaker 5: conditions that come together.
Speaker 5: How can you loosen that, the ties to those
Speaker 5: imprints?
Speaker 1: the way we listen to.
Speaker 1: Well, the way that we loosen the ties is by
Speaker 1: seeking to awaken to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: which is the deepest part of the self,
Speaker 1: which is which is the true self, and
Speaker 1: remember the which is the deepest part of
Speaker 1: the self, which is the true self, and
Speaker 1: remember the true self is the deepest and
Speaker 1: most authentic dimension of myself and
Speaker 1: yourself and of reality itself.
Speaker 1: But the true self is unattached and is
Speaker 1: eternal and therefore is unconditionally
Speaker 1: free.
Speaker 1: So if we dwell in the conscious awareness
Speaker 1: of our own true self, we will experience
Speaker 1: overwhelming freedom from all causes and
Speaker 1: effects, including all karmas.
Speaker 1: That's the relief.
Speaker 1: Awakening to enlightened awareness is the
Speaker 1: only relief.
Speaker 1: So the practice of meditation is a form of
Speaker 1: purification If we're really meditating.
Speaker 1: Yes, meditating means letting go of our
Speaker 1: attachment, our attachments.
Speaker 1: If we're really letting go and letting go
Speaker 1: of our attachments, if we're really
Speaker 1: meditating, then the answer is yes, but
Speaker 1: it's not so.
Speaker 1: Yes, it's a practice of purification, but
Speaker 1: it's also a practice of cultivating
Speaker 1: spiritual strength.
Speaker 1: Because the I'm contradicting what I said
Speaker 1: earlier, Because the less I'm contradicting
Speaker 1: what I said earlier I know that, but not
Speaker 1: less.
Speaker 1: Nobody's perfect.
Speaker 1: But the more we can let go, the less
Speaker 1: frightened we're going to be of karma and
Speaker 1: of responsibility, because we'll be
Speaker 1: connected with the inherent freedom that is
Speaker 1: the ground of all reality.
Speaker 1: So if we really learn how to let go and
Speaker 1: practice it diligently and do it just
Speaker 1: letting go is something you've got to do,
Speaker 1: we all have to do it it can become the
Speaker 1: source of what I call spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence, because spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence comes from the recognition
Speaker 1: that, at the deepest level, you are
Speaker 1: timeless and formless and beginningless and
Speaker 1: endless and eternal and inherently free,
Speaker 1: with a capital F, and you know it and you
Speaker 1: radiate that truth, and that becomes a
Speaker 1: source of spiritual self-confidence If you
Speaker 1: know it's true.
Speaker 5: So this is a form of forgiveness.
Speaker 5: You forgive yourself for your past.
Speaker 1: If you've done past actions that are, you
Speaker 1: know, bad, Well, self-forgiveness is always
Speaker 1: a good idea, but the awakening to the true
Speaker 1: self has nothing to do with
Speaker 1: self-forgiveness.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to the part of yourself that
Speaker 1: has never been born, never entered the
Speaker 1: stream of time, is always inherently free,
Speaker 1: so there's nothing to forgive.
Speaker 1: If nothing ever happens, there's nothing to
Speaker 1: forgive.
Speaker 5: So you're always looking forward, and not
Speaker 5: to the past or no, you learn from the past,
Speaker 5: but you can.
Speaker 5: You set your sights forward into evolution.
Speaker 1: That would be a very wholesome attitude, I
Speaker 1: think, a wholesome perspective a wholesome
Speaker 1: orientation now.
Speaker 1: Anna, letting go of the past and having a
Speaker 1: positive evolutionary orientation to the
Speaker 1: future.
Speaker 1: That sounds like something I would like to
Speaker 1: do.
Speaker 1: So that's why, kari, as I think you're
Speaker 1: aware, in the teaching of evolutionary
Speaker 1: enlightenment we have what's called the
Speaker 1: authentic self, the evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 1: And the evolutionary impulse, which is the
Speaker 1: energy and intelligence that created the
Speaker 1: universe, is the experience of pure
Speaker 1: positivity.
Speaker 1: It's the felt sense of recognition that all
Speaker 1: things are possible.
Speaker 1: And when you are awake to the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse, when I'm awake to the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse, the feeling, experience and state
Speaker 1: of consciousness is that all things are
Speaker 1: possible.
Speaker 1: It's the experience of pure positivity.
Speaker 1: It's a pure positivity that's a catalyst
Speaker 1: for creativity.
Speaker 1: Positivity, it's a pure positivity that's a
Speaker 1: catalyst for creativity.
Speaker 1: It's the feeling that all things are
Speaker 1: possible.
Speaker 1: When we get into a flow of spontaneous
Speaker 1: creativity, that's where we're overwhelmed
Speaker 1: with the sense that all things are possible,
Speaker 1: which is the experience of pure positivity.
Speaker 1: There's nothing in the way and all things
Speaker 1: are possible.
Speaker 1: There's no doubt and there's no fear.
Speaker 1: That's what the evolutionary impulse feels
Speaker 1: like, feels like pure positivity.
Speaker 1: And when I feel, when I'm awake to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse and I feel that all
Speaker 1: things are possible and you're awake to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse and you feel that all
Speaker 1: things are possible, we're going to get
Speaker 1: along great.
Speaker 1: We will be fabulous co-creators.
Speaker 1: Now, if I'm awake to the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse and I'm convinced that all things
Speaker 1: are possible and I'm overwhelmed with the
Speaker 1: pure positivity to the evolutionary impulse,
Speaker 1: and I'm convinced that all things are
Speaker 1: possible and I'm overwhelmed with the pure
Speaker 1: positivity of the evolutionary impulse, and
Speaker 1: you're stuck in your fear.
Speaker 1: You or anyone else would be trapped in the
Speaker 1: fear-ridden, doubt-laden, nihilistic,
Speaker 1: wounded ego.
Speaker 1: We're not going to be able to create much
Speaker 1: together, are we?
Speaker 1: Because I'll be wearing to go and you'll be
Speaker 1: licking your wounds.
Speaker 1: I don't mean you being you, I'm just using
Speaker 1: you as a metaphorically.
Speaker 1: You get my point.
Speaker 1: That's why, to create a new world, we all
Speaker 1: have to get over ourselves so we can do
Speaker 1: beautiful things together on the vantage
Speaker 1: point of the authentic self of the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 5: Now, right, Easy to say, but it's not
Speaker 5: always hard to do.
Speaker 5: It's often hard to do because things happen
Speaker 5: around you and trigger the illness in you
Speaker 5: and you have to wait it out until you get
Speaker 5: back to a place of positivity again.
Speaker 1: That's right.
Speaker 1: We Thank you.
Speaker 1: Nice to see you again, Kerry.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
Speaker 5: How are the dogs?
Speaker 1: Very good Happy campers.
Speaker 3: Great, thank you so the next question is
Speaker 3: from lorraine.
Speaker 3: She's asking have you experienced that the
Speaker 3: true self is the best guide for carrying
Speaker 3: action?
Speaker 1: no, no, no.
Speaker 1: In my experience, what I'm, what I've been
Speaker 1: describing in this talk, is the awakened
Speaker 1: soul is the best guide for carrying action,
Speaker 1: the being guided by the soul, felt urgings.
Speaker 1: What's the best guide for what kind of
Speaker 1: action?
Speaker 7: I'm sorry just caring action.
Speaker 7: It's easy to care about so many things I'm
Speaker 7: sorry, my picture doesn't work, my that
Speaker 7: doesn't work so it's easy to care about so
Speaker 7: many things that I found that I can get
Speaker 7: overwhelmed and super extended because I
Speaker 7: care about different things, different
Speaker 7: people, and so sometimes it's I have
Speaker 7: overextended myself, and so I just wondered
Speaker 7: where you find, if you find, a boundary so
Speaker 7: that you don't wear yourself down or then
Speaker 7: you need to be meditating more deeply,
Speaker 7: awakening to the true self and experiencing
Speaker 7: the freedom of being.
Speaker 7: Okay, I guess that's my answer and I
Speaker 7: appreciate it.
Speaker 1: That's how we recharge our metaphysical
Speaker 1: batteries.
Speaker 7: Yeah, and I probably got to a place where I
Speaker 7: didn't have that time for myself enough and
Speaker 7: I'm so I really I just super appreciate you
Speaker 7: talking about caring, because it's when
Speaker 7: it's just comes naturally and I can't say
Speaker 7: ego's involved, because you're just, it's
Speaker 7: just your heart, it's just your soul
Speaker 7: sometimes that just speaks to you to care
Speaker 7: and and I, um yeah, it's a humbling thing
Speaker 7: actually for me.
Speaker 7: So, but, thank you so much.
Speaker 7: This has been how you broke things down,
Speaker 7: has been really good for me.
Speaker 7: Thank you.
Speaker 7: So bless you, bless everybody on here.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 3: So almost at the end, you want to take one
Speaker 3: more question from Paul?
Speaker 1: Sure.
Speaker 3: He is asking, you are speaking about the
Speaker 3: soul as an aspect of the self which is
Speaker 3: imbued with a kind of implicit wisdom and
Speaker 3: intelligence, objectivity of ourselves and
Speaker 3: life, but also a developing intelligence,
Speaker 3: and that some things that our soul felt can
Speaker 3: even be motives of evil actions
Speaker 3: disconnected from a higher moral
Speaker 3: intelligence.
Speaker 3: It seems like there's a choosing faculty,
Speaker 3: but also a way that we interpret the soul's
Speaker 3: implicit wisdom and intelligence at higher
Speaker 3: levels.
Speaker 3: What is it in us that is choosing what we
Speaker 3: identify with?
Speaker 3: What part of our experience is interpreting
Speaker 3: the soul's intelligence?
Speaker 1: Well, I think it depends, Paul, on the
Speaker 1: fundamental distinctions of egocentric,
Speaker 1: ethnocentric, world-centric and
Speaker 1: cosmocentric.
Speaker 1: So, for example, if you were at an
Speaker 1: ethnocentric level of development and you
Speaker 1: decided that the and you were and something
Speaker 1: terrible had happened to your tribe, then
Speaker 1: you might feel it was very appropriate to
Speaker 1: kind of go massacre the next tribe, and the
Speaker 1: intelligence and the logic of that level of
Speaker 1: development would very much make it clear
Speaker 1: to you that that was a doubtlessly the
Speaker 1: right thing to do.
Speaker 1: But as you, as we evolve to higher, higher
Speaker 1: levels of stage development, you begin to
Speaker 1: see these, these, these relative issues, in
Speaker 1: bigger and bigger contexts.
Speaker 1: The capacity to see them in bigger and
Speaker 1: bigger contexts awakens our capacity for
Speaker 1: our discrimination and more and greater
Speaker 1: intelligence um, I guess there's, uh,
Speaker 1: there's this way that I guess.
Speaker 6: Um, I'm interpreting my.
Speaker 6: You know experience of the soul, or, like
Speaker 6: you said, that, experience of a rude
Speaker 6: awakening.
Speaker 6: You know experience of the soul, or, like
Speaker 6: you said, that experience of a rude
Speaker 6: awakening you?
Speaker 6: know which is that sense of like sudden
Speaker 6: objectivity about oneself.
Speaker 6: You know, it's like seeing oneself
Speaker 6: incredibly clearly in a way that uh, it's
Speaker 6: kind of like uh, the warts and all
Speaker 6: experience and um, and, but in that
Speaker 6: experience of the rude awakening there's
Speaker 6: that, there's that sense of like a cosmic
Speaker 6: objectivity.
Speaker 6: You know, um, it's not rooted necessarily
Speaker 6: in my individual um, uh, unlimited to the
Speaker 6: value system, you know it's.
Speaker 6: It's kind of like I'm now seeing myself
Speaker 6: outside of my ego's kind of value system or
Speaker 6: construct, right, I'm no longer hiding.
Speaker 6: So it's like, in that no longer hiding,
Speaker 6: there's this intelligence that becomes
Speaker 6: active, there's a way of seeing clearly
Speaker 6: that becomes active.
Speaker 6: So there's that sense of you know this
Speaker 6: simplistic quality of extraordinary wisdom.
Speaker 6: You know complete wisdom that sometimes can
Speaker 6: arise, for instance in meditation or in
Speaker 6: contemplation with others, that is sort of
Speaker 6: free from my.
Speaker 6: You know, individual ego in that way, ego
Speaker 6: in that way, and and it and it felt that,
Speaker 6: like the way that you were speaking to
Speaker 6: developing the soul or awakening the soul,
Speaker 6: it's kind of you're also stirring or
Speaker 6: awakening this extraordinary intelligence
Speaker 6: and wisdom to become even more active.
Speaker 6: You know, or an awakened aspect of our
Speaker 6: psyche.
Speaker 1: You know an awakened aspect of our psyche
Speaker 1: you know, this aspect of definitely and
Speaker 1: definitely, definitely, but I, I,
Speaker 1: definitely, but in my, in my experience,
Speaker 1: what I was trying to describe, even though
Speaker 1: there is intelligence and self-reliance,
Speaker 1: self-reflectivity, self-reflectivity and
Speaker 1: having this kind of experience, I'm
Speaker 1: speaking more, more about a feeling in
Speaker 1: which there's enormous gravitas and
Speaker 1: poignancy, about this larger context in
Speaker 1: which we see ourselves and it's it's the
Speaker 1: sense of gravitas and emotional and there's
Speaker 1: a great emotional intensity that tells us
Speaker 1: this is very, very important.
Speaker 1: It's when we feel the weight of karma, in a
Speaker 1: way.
Speaker 6: Sorry no, sorry, continue the weight of
Speaker 6: karma that would compel us to act so would
Speaker 6: you then kind of say that the, the
Speaker 6: awakening of this aspect of our soul are,
Speaker 6: or this deepest part of ourself is, is
Speaker 6: literally one with kind of one's ability to
Speaker 6: recognize like importance and significance
Speaker 6: in a way that is extraordinarily deep and
Speaker 6: real?
Speaker 6: Real, like absolutely, that's like yeah
Speaker 6: okay, so it is.
Speaker 6: It's kind of like that awakening of, of, uh,
Speaker 6: the mind or our intelligence that just
Speaker 6: feels actual gravitas and importance, and
Speaker 6: and from that is where we, that sense of
Speaker 6: care emerges it's a sense of care, but
Speaker 6: there's a sense of um, of truth, and truth
Speaker 6: and rightness.
Speaker 1: In other words, if we, in other words, if
Speaker 1: we're not lying to ourself and we are, and
Speaker 1: we're daring to allow ourselves to be
Speaker 1: utterly vulnerable, transparent,
Speaker 1: transparent before our maker, then often we
Speaker 1: realize, in relationship to important
Speaker 1: issues in life, that we really don't have
Speaker 1: any choices anymore.
Speaker 1: As we see, there's the next step of what's
Speaker 1: appropriate begins.
Speaker 1: As we've seen us being obvious, it's not
Speaker 1: even what we want anymore.
Speaker 1: It's about what needs to happen, what
Speaker 1: should happen, because of all the causes
Speaker 1: that have let it, let us up to that moment
Speaker 1: that we, that we can temporarily see very
Speaker 1: clearly then.
Speaker 6: So I guess the other uh uh aspect of this
Speaker 6: that I would love for you to maybe clarify,
Speaker 6: and how you experience it yourself and and
Speaker 6: how you're kind of conceptualizing this, is
Speaker 6: the you know there's.
Speaker 6: You know, obviously there's a way that we
Speaker 6: kind of, in our dualistic thinking, kind of
Speaker 6: compartmentalize aspects of ourselves and
Speaker 6: kind of objectify them.
Speaker 6: In a way, we um disconnect ourselves from
Speaker 6: realizing kind of our unity with right, so
Speaker 6: like the self is not just like a, an organ
Speaker 6: perhaps, but it's, it's a um, you know,
Speaker 6: when we're experiencing it's for lack of a
Speaker 6: better word like refuge in the soul, there
Speaker 6: is a unity with right, it's a kind of we
Speaker 6: are one with that soul, it's an aspect of
Speaker 6: me.
Speaker 6: It's not just, uh, something I'm
Speaker 6: intellectually kind of seeing as a
Speaker 6: particular organ of my um self right and um
Speaker 6: the so so it kind of, uh, I guess there's
Speaker 6: that sense of um, does the sorry, let me uh
Speaker 6: try to formulate my question here um, I
Speaker 6: guess there's this.
Speaker 6: You know, know, awakening to the hey, this
Speaker 6: is the deepest part of myself and from how
Speaker 6: you're saying, it's kind of it's where our
Speaker 6: sense of care and significance and
Speaker 6: importance ultimately would direct our, our
Speaker 6: choosing and our acting.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 6: So the still there's this kind of, in my
Speaker 6: mind at least, when I'm trying to
Speaker 6: conceptualize and understand this.
Speaker 6: Is it kind of in purifying my relationship
Speaker 6: to, let's say, the soul, recognizing more
Speaker 6: deeply my unity with the soul, is it kind
Speaker 6: of?
Speaker 1: it's a, would you say it's also a revealing
Speaker 1: that the soul is the actor, the soul is the
Speaker 1: chooser seeing that the choosing well, not
Speaker 1: always okay, so then so sometimes you can
Speaker 1: realize well that your soul could have
Speaker 1: revealed something to you that you didn't
Speaker 1: respond to because you weren't ready or you
Speaker 1: didn't want to.
Speaker 6: So I guess for me it's like it still begs.
Speaker 6: The question is like who is the doer, you
Speaker 6: know, or the actor, or the shooter?
Speaker 6: That's a long question.
Speaker 1: Well, we can go into this next time, but
Speaker 1: the doer is whoever's making the choices.
Speaker 1: Whichever part of yourself is making the
Speaker 1: choices, he's the one who's the doer.
Speaker 1: So, on a good, on a good day, it'll be the
Speaker 1: soul and a bad day, it'll be the ego I
Speaker 1: guess like it, but there's a.
Speaker 6: There's a there's the meta doer that's
Speaker 6: choosing between.
Speaker 1: But there's a there's a, there's the meta
Speaker 1: doer, that's choosing between those two.
Speaker 1: Would you say no, no, no, no, okay or is
Speaker 1: that just like?
Speaker 6: is that it's just an illusion of kind of
Speaker 6: conditioning?
Speaker 1: would you say.
Speaker 1: I'm not sure what you're referring to, but
Speaker 1: sometimes we make the right choices for the
Speaker 1: right reasons.
Speaker 1: Sometimes we make the wrong choices for the
Speaker 1: wrong reasons and then sometimes we wake up,
Speaker 1: and still wake up a day later, a year later,
Speaker 1: a lifetime later, and say, oy vey, what did
Speaker 1: I do?
Speaker 1: Right and it's an advantage point of an
Speaker 1: awakened soul, awakened consciousness, we
Speaker 1: can see more clearly the forces that would
Speaker 1: work within us and why we made the choices
Speaker 1: that we did.
Speaker 6: Right.
Speaker 6: So I mean I, and I understand kind of the,
Speaker 6: of course, like the concept that our
Speaker 6: decisions can be, you know, uh, influenced
Speaker 6: by, let's say, like the voice of the ego
Speaker 6: within us, right that fundamentally kind of
Speaker 6: overtakes or overrides or kind of colors
Speaker 6: that say the chooser.
Speaker 1: No, but again, it depends which voices are
Speaker 1: we listening to.
Speaker 6: Right.
Speaker 6: So so just to say like, like, if we just
Speaker 6: use the polarity of the you know the, the
Speaker 6: soul versus, or the you know authentic self
Speaker 6: versus the ego, there's still, like the
Speaker 6: chooser that is picking between the two,
Speaker 6: would you right?
Speaker 6: Is that correct?
Speaker 1: But if you choose the authentic self, and
Speaker 1: that's the chooser.
Speaker 1: If you choose the ego, then that's the
Speaker 1: chooser.
Speaker 6: Okay.
Speaker 6: So you're just kind of saying then and you
Speaker 6: know, I'm just trying to work it out that
Speaker 6: that there's kind of like two choosers is
Speaker 6: like a meta chooser, and then there's a
Speaker 6: which is choosing between the choosers, or
Speaker 6: and then there's like but what?
Speaker 1: you were calling the meta chooser doesn't
Speaker 1: last long.
Speaker 1: The meta chooser becomes whichever part of
Speaker 1: yourself made the choice to go one way or
Speaker 1: the other.
Speaker 5: That's the chooser, whichever part of
Speaker 5: yourself made it made the choice to go one
Speaker 5: way or the other, that because that that's
Speaker 5: the choosing.
Speaker 6: So the, um, I guess, like the, there's a
Speaker 6: way that you're saying hey, like when you
Speaker 6: like what you choose, you become.
Speaker 6: You're right, like the yes you're, man,
Speaker 6: you're, you are manifesting like the ego or
Speaker 6: the authentic self, or let's say like
Speaker 6: soul's care absolutely yes right.
Speaker 6: So I, I suppose, and maybe it's just
Speaker 6: something to to dive deeper into at another
Speaker 6: point, because it sounds like it's
Speaker 6: something to- takes more time to tease
Speaker 6: apart, but we should.
Speaker 1: We should do that.
Speaker 1: But what I'm saying is what you're calling
Speaker 1: the meta chooser is not eternally present,
Speaker 1: it's not a constant not eternally present
Speaker 1: it's not okay, what?
Speaker 6: but if it's not eternally present, how is
Speaker 6: it then that, let's say, if I become the
Speaker 6: ego chooser, right?
Speaker 6: How is it that the ego chooser could ever
Speaker 6: then become the soul chooser?
Speaker 6: Do you see what I mean?
Speaker 1: It would be stuck, it's because there's
Speaker 1: still hope for your soul.
Speaker 1: But the thing is because, as long as
Speaker 1: there's still hope for your soul.
Speaker 1: But the point is, if you keep giving in to
Speaker 1: the ego, and then that will start creating
Speaker 1: so much momentum that you won't be able to
Speaker 1: get out of it Because you and then that
Speaker 1: will start creating so much momentum that
Speaker 1: you won't be able to get out of it, because
Speaker 1: you won't be able to even see the soul
Speaker 1: anymore in yourself.
Speaker 1: You won't be able to make that distinction
Speaker 1: because your soul, the world of the ego and
Speaker 1: its likes and dislikes and its preferences
Speaker 1: start becoming more and more real because
Speaker 1: you keep giving in to them.
Speaker 1: One keeps giving in to them, and then the
Speaker 1: whole world of the soul and its greater
Speaker 1: gravity sets us in depth.
Speaker 1: We begin to lose sight of it unless there's
Speaker 1: some massive event in our life that
Speaker 1: reawakens us to it.
Speaker 1: If we keep choosing the ego, we can lose
Speaker 1: touch with our own souls, as many people do.
Speaker 1: And in the same way, if we start choosing
Speaker 1: for our souls and even the faces of the
Speaker 1: temptation to do otherwise, keep choosing
Speaker 1: it, then our awareness of the forces of the
Speaker 1: soul, depth of the soul, the gravitas of
Speaker 1: the soul becomes more and more available to
Speaker 1: us, more and more apparent to us like.
Speaker 6: There's like in my experience.
Speaker 6: You know there's something extraordinary
Speaker 6: when the chooser becomes like experiences,
Speaker 6: a sense of union with the soul yes, that's
Speaker 6: the whole idea it's kind of like, it feels
Speaker 6: like, kind of like at home.
Speaker 6: Right, it's like the personality construct
Speaker 6: and the choosing well.
Speaker 1: Well, it'll feel at home.
Speaker 1: It's not sorry to interrupt you.
Speaker 1: It'll feel at home.
Speaker 1: You'll feel at home if you've, if the soul
Speaker 1: is the direction you're leaning in.
Speaker 1: But if you've been leaning in the direction
Speaker 1: of the ego for a long time, if one has been
Speaker 1: leaning in the direction of ego for a long
Speaker 1: time and consistently been choosing for
Speaker 1: that, the soul will feel like a very
Speaker 1: uncomfortable.
Speaker 1: What we're calling the soul will feel a
Speaker 1: very uncomfortable place to be get out of
Speaker 1: quick.
Speaker 6: Um would.
Speaker 6: Would you say, though, that, even like, um
Speaker 6: like to the degree to which you're you've
Speaker 6: become more acclimated, or you've been
Speaker 6: leaning in that direction more acclimated,
Speaker 6: or you've been leaning in that direction,
Speaker 6: nevertheless, or uh that that the, the
Speaker 6: choosing faculty, can feel a quality of
Speaker 6: non-duality with the soul in a way it
Speaker 6: cannot with the ego?
Speaker 1: no, it can feel non-duality with the egos
Speaker 1: if it's very identified with it okay,
Speaker 1: interesting.
Speaker 6: So there's.
Speaker 6: I'm just trying to tease apart aspects of
Speaker 6: my experience and what you're saying, um
Speaker 6: cool to be continued okay to be continued.
Speaker 1: Thank you, andrew thank you, lovely to see
Speaker 1: you much love.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.